es Abendessen vorgesehen und vor den
Gesprächen noch bevor die Gespräche
beginnen soll es auch ein Statement
geben von Bundeskanzler Scholz und dem
türkischen Präsidenten Erdogan erst hieß
es vielleicht eine Pressekonferenz nach
dem Gespräch aber nein sie wollen sich
jetzt vorher äußern wir sind jetzt drin
im Bundeskanzleramt in Berlin wir müssen
jetzt warten wir haben ja gesehen die
beiden sind gerade reingelaufen sie
gehen jetzt noch die Treppe hoch
vielleicht kann ich noch was sagen als
Erdogan heute Nachmittag bei bundesprä
ent Steinmeier war da hat der
Bundespräsident klar gemacht dass sie
den Standpunkt was Israel betrifft der
türkische Präsident hat von einem
Terrorstaat gesprochen zu in keinster
Weise teilen und sie haben auch gesagt
die Hamas ist eine
Terrororganisation sie haben also ganz
klare Kante gezeigt der Bundespräsident
Übereinstimmung zwischen frankwalter
Steinmeier und Erdogan besteht
allerdings in der Frage dass es oberste
Priorität hat die Geiseln die in den
Händen der terrororganis Hamas sind
jetzt zu befreien es gab ja heute eine
weitere traurige Nachricht dass eine
19-jährige Soldatin von der israelischen
Armee tot die auch gekidnappt worden war
von derchamas in der Nähe des alschifa
Krankenhaus gefunden worden war gestern
Abend eine Frau 65 Jahre alt wir
erinnern uns auch tot gefunden in der
Nähe dieser größten Klinik in Gaza so
und jetzt erwarten wir mit Spannung wie
gesagt der der Besuche war nicht ist
nicht unumstritten es ist auch davon
auszugehen erst dieses Jahr es war
gemutmaßt worden dass der türkische
Präsident sich morgen eventuell noch im
Berliner Olympiastadion das
Freundschaftsspiel angucken könnte
zwischen Deutschland und der Türkei
stolz mit der Kapitänsbinde wird ja der
türkische Spieler elk güuan auflaufen
und das ist soll aber nicht so sein es
heißt jetzt der türkische Präsident will
heute Abend wohl noch
zurückkehren in die Türkei und ich denke
jetzt mal es handelt sich jetzt nur noch
um wenige Augenblicke ja zu besprechen
gibt es viel wie gesagt also eine
möglichst schnelle Freilassung der
Geiseln dass man die Leben rettet und
natürlich geht es auch um das Stichwort
Migration der migrationspakt mit der
Europäischen Union in der Türkei ist der
quasi tot ab man den wiederbeleben kann
vielleicht auch ob es eine
migrationsabkommen
zwischen Deutschland und der Türkei
geben soll weil viele geflüchtete die
bei uns ankommen kommen aus der Türkei
verstärkt nach der letzten Wahl wo sich
Erdogan als Präsident durchgesetzt hat
natürlich wird es wahrscheinlich auch um
die Ukraine gehen und die Türkei ist ein
natopartner die Türkei wünscht sich z.B
auch Eurofighter 16 Stück an der Zahl
ja und wie man da zusammen klar kommmt
wie man übereinkommt wie man
eine gemeinsame Linie findet trotz aller
Meinungsunterschiede das wird natürlich
die Frage sein weil der türkische
Präsident hat sich ja da auf der
internationalen Bühne als Vermittler
eine Art Global Player einen Namen
gemacht er hat immer noch Kontakte gute
Kontakte zu Russland hat den Deal mit
dem getreideabkommen mit der Ukraine
verhandelt er hat ja er hat natürlich
gute Kontakte zum Iran er hat sich auch
zu Hamas eindeutig positioniert und die
Frage war ist das richtig ihn jetzt zu
treffen dieser Besuch war vor langer
Zeit schon vereinbart worden der
türkische Präsident war das letzte Mal
in Deutschland
2018 und der Tenor aus Berlin war gerade
in solchen schwierigen Zeiten muss man
reden man muss die Unterschiede klar
herausstellen klare Kante zeigen wie das
der Bundespräsident heute Nachmittag
getan hat aber trotzdem nach
Kompromissen suchen und
den Gesprächsfaden miteinander nicht
verlieren ja wie gesagt wir warten jetzt
noch es kann auch sein dass die beiden
sich erstmal kurz besprechen weil das
verzögert sich jetzt doch um einige Zeit
ich gucke mal gerade
ich würde vorschlagen die Regie
vielleicht können wir mal wir haben ja
ein Studi Gast hier und vielleicht
können wir mal schnell das Gespräch nach
Bonn suchen wenn nicht bleiben wir
natürlich hier drauf das ist alles live
so jetzt sehe ich gerade wir sind hier
zurück in Bonn bei mir im Studio ist
Atila asrak deutschttürkischer
Journalist also mit türkischen Wurzeln
in Berlin geboren in der Türkei sind sie
aufgewachsen dann sind sie wieder
zurückgekommen ja was meinen Sie denn
welche Erwartungen gibt es denn an
dieses Gespräch was könnte man denn von
Erdogan maximal erwarten was erwartet
der türkische Präsident wenn er heute
mit dem deutschen Bundeskanzler
zusammensitzt also der türkische
Präsident tritt
erstmal nicht als bitsteller auf sondern
er will natürlich wieder Präsenz zeigen
in Deutschland in Europa äh aber auf der
anderen Seite muss man natürlich auch
wissen äh dass die Türkei in einer
schlimmen Wirtschaftskrise steckt
äh das Volk ist sehr
äh ja aufgebracht eigentlich äh wieder
wir müssen mal ganz kurz wieder rüber
gehen nach Berlin ich sehe die beiden
Statements der türkische Präsident der
deutsche Bundeskanzler und wir hören
zu
sehr gehehte Damen und Herren ich
begrüße den türkischen Staatspräsidenten
hier in Berlin es ist gut Herr Präsident
dass wir die Gelegenheit haben werden
direkt miteinander zu sprechen uns
beschäftigen beide die Krisen in dieser
Welt da ist zunächst der russische
Überfall auf die Ukraine und seine
weitreichenden Folgen unter denen fast
die ganze Welt zu leiden hat wir beide
sind uns einig Russland muss seine
Aggression so schnell wie möglich
beenden die Türkei hat eine konstruktive
und wichtige Rolle gespielt in der Frage
die ukrainisches Getreide trotz der
anhaltenden Kämpfe exportiert werden
kann ich möchte dem türkischen
Präsidenten für
seine persönlichen Einsatz in dieser
wichtigen Angelegenheit ausdrücklich
danken es ist bitter dass Moskau dieses
Abkommen nicht länger
fortführt Russland verstößt mit dem
Krieg gegen eine lange besteh
üereinkopft dass Grenzen nicht gewaltsam
verschoben werden dürfen das habe ich
als Zeitenwende bezeichnet denn es
gefährdet die europäische Sicherheit
gleich werden wir auch darüber sprechen
wie es um die Aufnahme Schwedens in die
NATO steht das türkische Parlament
beredt derzeit über die Ratifikation der
Aufnahme wir hoffen auf einen baldigen
positiven Beschluss denn es geht darum
die NATO als Bündnis zu
stärken ein weiteres sehr wichtiges
Thema ist natürlich die Situation im
Nahen Osten am 7 oktober hat die Hamas
Israel auf barbarische Weise
angegriffen die Bundesregierung
verurteilt diesen Terrorakt der Hamas
auf das
Schärfste wir werden gleich darüber
sprechen wie wir eine weitere Eskalation
in der Region verhindern können denn wir
teilen die Sorge vor einem Flächenbrand
im Nahen
Osten wer Deutschland kennt der weiß
unsere Solidarität mit Israel steht
außer Frage israel hat das
völkerrechtlich verbriefte Recht sich zu
verteidigen gleichzeitig sagen wir jedes
Leben ist gleich viel wert auch das Leid
der palästinensischen Zivilbevölkerung
in Gaza bedrückt uns seit Jahrzehnten
gehört Deutschland zu den größten Gebern
humanitärer Hilfe für die
palästinensische Bevölkerung wir haben
jetzt unsere humanitäre Hilfe in diesem
Jahr noch einmal auf mehr als 160
Millionen Euro erhöht und gehören damit
zu den größten Gebern humanitärer
Hilfe der gegenwärtige Konflikt ist uns
auch Anlass den Blick zu lenken auf die
notwendige langfristige politische
Lösung des
Nahostkonflikts eine Zweistaatenlösung
bleibt für uns das erklärte
Ziel lassen Sie mich ganz klar sagen das
Existenzrecht Israels ist für uns
unumstößlich und lassen Sie mich genauso
klar sagen in unserem Land ist kein
Platz für Antisemitismus egal ob er
politisch motiviert ist oder religiös ob
er von rechts kommt oder von links ob er
seit Jahrhunderten hier gewachsen ist
oder von außen ins Land
kommt und zugleich trete ich all
denjenigen entgegen die nun allen 5
Millionen Musliminnen und Muslimen in
Deutschland ihren Platz in unserem Land
ab sprechen wollen gegen solche Versuche
wende ich mich genauso
entschlossen meine Damen und Herren der
Nahe und Mittlere Osten ist seit langem
eine Region großer Spannung weil es
unsere Nachbarregion ist kann das was
dort geschieht uns nicht gleichgültig
sein Herr Präsident dass wir zu dem
aktuellen Konflikt unterschiedliche zum
Teil sehr unterschiedliche Sicht Wasen
haben ist ja kein Geheimnis gerade
deshalb sind unsere Gespräche wichtig
gerade in schwierigen Augenblicken
brauchen wir das direkte Gespräch
miteinander jenseits dieser akuten
internationalen Themen werden wir gleich
auch darüber sprechen wie wir in unseren
bilateralen Beziehungen und in den
Beziehung der Türkei zur Europäischen
Union konkrete Fortschritte erreichen
können in den vergangenen Jahren sind
wir in den Beziehung zwischen der EU und
der Türkei hinter unseren Möglichkeiten
hinter unserem Potenzial
zurückgeblieben mit Präsident Erdogan
werde ich diskutieren wie wir hier
vorankommen
können Flucht und irreguläre Migration
sind ein weiteres zentrales Thema uns
eint das Ziel irreguläre Migration zu
begrenzen die Türkei und die Europäische
Union haben im Jahr 2016 eine wie ich
finde gute Vereinbarung
getroffen ich setze mich in der
Europäischen Union dafür ein dass diese
Vereinbarung fortgesetzt wird sie ist zu
unser beiderseitigem Nutzen und auch
über die Frage der Rückführung werden
wir sprechen
müssen die Bürgerin und Bürger
Deutschlands und der Türkei sind auf
vielfältige Weise miteinander verbunden
mir ist wichtig dass der Kontakt die
persönlichen Begegnung für unsere Bürger
gut und möglichst unkompliziert
gestaltet wird auch das werden wir
diskutieren das Erdbeben in der Region
gasianep im Februar hat gezeigt dass
sich die Menschen in unseren beiden
Ländern besonders eng verbunden fühlen
sofort hat Deutschland mit Bergungsteams
geholfen ein Lazarett der Bundeswehr
bereitgestellt und den kurzzeitigen
Aufenthalt mehrerer tausend Betroffener
in Deutschland ermöglicht für den
Wiederaufbau haben wir Finanzmittel zur
Verfügung gestellt und werden ihn weiter
unterstützen großes Potenzial besteht
auch in Fragen wirtschaftlicher
Zusammenarbeit den gegenseitigen Handel
sollten wir weiter ausbauen
Rechtssicherheit für Unternehmen und
eine stabile Finanz und
Wirtschaftspolitik sind dafür wichtige
Grundlagen sie sehen wir haben ein
volles Programm vor uns für heute Abend
schönen
Dank
ش
herlichent
Stein und bei dem Herrn Bundeskanzler
Scholz
herzlich danken für die
Gastfreundlichkeit dieser Besuch auf
Einladung von Herr Scholz ist sehr
wichtig für mich und wir werden gleich
auch im Rahmen der bilateralen
Beziehungen der Gespräche die wir fühen
werden natürlich die
viimensionalen Beziehungen besprechen
können dies bezüglich gibt es natürlich
wirtschaftliche Komponenten militärische
Komponenten auch die Entwicklungen wenn
wir vom russischukrainischen Krieg
sprechen und dann
natürlich zwischen Israel und
Palästina Ereignisse Entwicklungen auch
diese Dimension werden wir gleich ja
Örtern ich spreche immer ganz offen auch
hier denn der 7
Oktober ist oder wird als
Anfang
dargestellt und das Prozedere sozusagen
auch
danach wird weniger dargestellt wir
sprechen von 13000 Kindern
Frauen alten
Menschen die getötet worden
sind
daneben gibt es eigentlich fast
überhaupt nicht mehr einen Punkt den man
Gaza nennen kann alles ist dem erdboben
gleich gemacht
worden und jeder spricht von
Hamas von morgens bis abends auch die
Waffen oder die Kraft die Macht der
Hamas kann man das überhaup vergleichen
mit dem was Israel hat
is hat Israel eine nukleare Waffe
ja wenn sie Israel Fragen wird Israel
nicht ja sagen weil sie natürlich nicht
unbedingt die
Wahrheit
sagen es wird immer davon gesprochen
dass man
finanziell Unterstützung gewährleistet
Israel wird Hamas auch solche eine
Unterstützung gewährleistet natürlich
nicht
Palästina die Unterstützung die
Palästina erhalten müsste auch diese
werden nicht erteilt und in dieser Not
ist es vielleicht auch folgendes sehr
wichtig Gotteshäuser Gebetshäuser werden
zerbomt Kirchen werden
zerbomt damit auch
Krankenhäuser
obwohl neben
allem
dieombierung von krankenhäus das Töten
von Kindern das gibt es in der Tora
nicht das können sie
nicht auch in der allgemeinen
Menschenrechtserklärung auch in diesem
zus kann man das nicht aber wie werden
diese und wurden diese Kinder getötet
werden die Menschen in den
Krankenhäusern getötet
und werden wir dort einfach nur
Schweigen werden wir unsere Stimme nicht
erheben und wenn wir unsere Stimme nicht
erheben wenn wir nichts tun wie werden
wir den Preis dann zahlen in der
Geschichte wenn man dann zurückblickt
und in
dieser
Psychologie
eines vielleicht dass man sozusagen in
einer schuldpsychologie sich befindet
darf man das so nicht bewerten weil wir
sind und haben keine
Schulden bei
Israel wenn das so wä dann könnten wir
vielleicht nicht so ganz einfach
reden
wir sind auch nicht eben durch
diesen Werdegang des Holocaust
gegangen weil der Respekt
Menschen ist sehr wichtig und ich
Präsident
war bin ich ein Ministerpräsident
gewesen der ganz har Reaktion gezeigt
hat eben wenn es um Antisemitismus ging
auch damals habe ich mich entsprechend
ausgesprochen von daher haben wir auch
bei niemanden Schulden Schulden auch
niemand bei unser dieser Reise bei
diesem Besuch werden wir das natürlich
besprechen aber daneben natürlich
müssen wir
auch einen weiteren wichtigen Punkt
besprechen wie können wir das Problem
lösen also eine humanitäre
Waffen
Pause inwiern kann die Türkei eine
Beitrag leisten Deutschland einen
Beitrag leisten und wie können wir diese
Schritte gemeinsam tun das ist wichtig
jetzt und sind wir bereit das zu tun
oder nicht nach einer W wird Steiner
nach Israel reisen ich habe ihn
gebeten bitte nehmen Sie da die Sache
von einer Seite an wir von einer anderen
Sache anderen Seite an und versuchen wir
gemeinsam sozusagen diese humanitäre
Waffenruhe zu
gewährleisten und wenn wir diesen
Schritt tun können wenn wir als eine
humanitäre
waffenpuse
Waffenruhe Türkei Deutschland und andere
Länder das gewährleisten
können dann können wir das Gebiet aus
dieser schwierigen Situation aus dieser
diesem Feuer
retten und wir sind auch bereit
natürlich zu helfen wenn es dabei um die
Geiseln geht um die Rettung der Geiseln
geht
aber wie steht es um die Zahl der
Geiseln auf der anderen Seite in Israel
der Palästinenser
und was ist die Zahl der Geiseln
sozusagen auf der palästinensischen
Seite wenn wir von den Geiseln zulzt
sprechen und in Israel gibt es ja das
mehrfache von Geiseln sozusagen mehr
oder
weniger an
Palästinensern ein Großzahl die gefangen
sind momentan in Israel auch das müssen
wir sehen wenn wir das nicht sehen wäre
das nicht
fair und wir sind zu allem bereit zu
helfen
genauso wie wir im Schwarzen Meer im
Rahmen eines getreidekorridors
vermittelt
haben und somit natürlich auch Europa
Afrika da haben wir nicht unterschieden
das zugute gekommen ist und ich sage
ganz klar und
deutlich ein
getreidekorridor vom Schwarzen Meer und
das was dort gekommen ist ist 40% nach
europa%
ka 40% in die Türkei und der Rest in die
Welt und es gibt momentan auch aus
Afrika wieder
Anfragen und Russland wird eine große
Menge an
Getreide
wieder nach Afrika schicken aber es gibt
gewisse Probleme was sind das für
Probleme ich glaube Simbabwe wird es
sein wenn ich mich richtig entsinne dort
geht zwar Getreide
hin aber das muss ja sozusagen zu Mehl
verarbeitet werden das haben die dort
nicht da habe ich gesagt das können wir
machen das übernehmen wir als
Türkei wir werden das in unseren
entsprechenden
mehlfabriken verarbeiten und werden das
dann
weiterschicken in diese Länder oder in
dieses Land also es sind Schritte die
wir tun müssen das übernehmen wir
und es sind vier bis fünf Länder
beispiitsweise wo auch Russland über
diesen Korridor
Getreide schicken möchte und plant und
wir wären dann in der zweiten Etape das
heißt die Umwandlung in Mehl dann soweit
dass wir das
Übernehmen genauso wie eben über
Russland eben die Türkei und Katar wie
entsprechende Schritte unternommen haben
das würden wir
machen und damit diese Schritte
unternommen werden
können muss es zwischen der Türkei und
Deutschland auch diesen Schritt
geben und unser NATO Verbündeter
Deutschland muss natürlich dabei auch
mit entschlossenen
Schritten vorangehen wen wir
beispielsweise auch diesbezüglich von
Rüstungsgüter und der Industrie sprechen
und den Export sprechen das muss
ungehindert möglich sein wir wollen
natürlich auch in der in mit Deutschland
in diesen Bereichen in der Wirtschaft
auch noch enger
zusammenarbeiten und wenn
wir von der türkischen Gemeinde mit
einer Zahl von 3,5 Millionen Menschen
ausgehen ist dies natürlich eine
menschliche Brücke die sehr wichtig ist
zwischen unseren beiden Ländern
um denöen bedüren der türkchen
gemeinschftgcht zu werden arbeiten wir
auch gemeinsam an der Ausbildung der
tätigen
regigionsbeauftragten ein weiterer Punkt
den wir bespre werden ist natürlich die
Migration und es gibt eine gemeinsame
Arbeitsgruppe die
tagt ein weiterer Punkt
wäre insbesondere natürlich der euitt
zess der Türkei ein wichtiger
Gesprächspunkt und wir wünschen uns
natürlich ganz enigst dass dieser
Beitrittsprozess weitergeht dass die
Zollunion modernisiert wird aber auch
die Visa
Liberalisierung sind Themen wo wir auch
berechtigte Erwartungen
haben eine der Motoren der Europäischen
Union also Deutschland und die
Unterstützung Deutschlands dabei ist
natürlich für un
und das ist gar nicht so einfach seit 52
Jahren wartet die Türkei an der Tür der
Europäischen
Union und bis die Visaliberalisierung
gewährleistet wird sollten auch die vis
Verfahren vereinfacht werden
beschleunigt werden und auch das werden
wir heute besprechen sehrhrte Vertreter
der
Presse werden natürlich das was in Gaza
sich abspielt sicherlich auch noch etwas
intensiver oben besprechen aber wir als
Türkei sind stets natürlich von Anfang
an gegen Angriffe auf zivile Menschen
gewesen und sind es immer wieder und
auch bei jedem Gespräch haben wir das
zur Sprache gebrachtt und prioritär wäre
zunächst einmal eine
Waffenpause
und dass dabei auch die entsprechenden
Hilfsgüter ungehindert
nach Gaza kommen Flugzeuge voll haben
die humanitäre
Hilfe zunächst nach Ägypten
geschickt und ganz
zuletzt per Schiff
Tonnen
Lebensmittel dann ein Lazarett oder
merere Lazaret wurden
dorthineschickt aber das Problem ist
natürlich dass zunächst einmal das
fließende Blut gestoppt
wird 27 krebskranke
Patienten und auch die entsprechenden
Begleitpersonen wurden in die Türkei von
El in die Türkei gebracht
zuletzt und gestern habe ich sie auch im
Krankenhaus
besucht und hab nach deren Wohlbefinden
gefragt und ich hoffe dass
wir noch mehr Patienten verwundete oder
auch krebskranke insbesondere Patienten
in unser Land bringen und dann auch
deren
Pflege in der Türke
V und hier ist es wichtig natürlich eine
zwei Staaten Lösung nach den Grenzen von
1967 was unabdingbar nun erforderlich zu
sein scheint wir als
Türkei ist es unser Ziel ein Klima zu
schaffen Israelis und Palästinenser
Seite an Seite in Frieden und in
Sicherheit leben können das müssen wir
schaffen
und hier muss natürlich jeder für eine
entsprechende Atmosphäre von Sicherheit
und Frieden und der Umsetzung dieses
Friedens Verantwortung übernehmen ich
möchte mich zum Abschluss meiner ung
noch einmal ganz herzlich für die
Einladung und für die
Gastfreundschaft
bedanken und hoffe dass unser Besuch für
unsere beiden Länder und die
Solidarität aber auch für die Region
Gutes bringt vielen
Dank geht her bundler
scholzäent kann natürlich auch seine
Meung dazu sagen die Türkei
ist natürlich nicht gleichgültig
geblieben gegenüber der Situation in
Gaza und hat Patienten in die Türkei
geholt das hat eben der Präsident gesagt
aber auch als Garant sozusagen als
Mittlerrolle der Türkei dafür ist die
Türkei auch da wo der gesagt wenn es
dabei um eine Friedenslösung gehen
sollte und auch die Evakuierung der
Menschen sozusagen aus dieser Region
Deutschland ganz voran oder die
Europäische Union was gedenken Sie zu
tun in diesem Zusammenhang zumindest
wenn es dabei z.B um die Evakuierung um
Patienten um kranke Menschen geht kann
man da einen gemeinsamen Mechanismus
bilden was sagt Deutschland dazu und
Israel tötet alle 10 Minuten ein Kind in
Gaza und das ist natürlich beschämend im
Namen der
Menschlichkeit dch mus denken sie dass
Israel auf internationaler rechtslicher
Ebene angeklagt werden
muss also vielleicht ein paar kurze
Bemerkung von meiner Seite aus zu nächst
mal ich habe es bereits in meinem
Statement gesagt israel hat einen
Selbstverteidigungsrecht es war ein
furchtbarer brutaler Angriff den die
Hamas gemacht hat auf Kinder auf ältere
auf friedensbewegte auf diejenigen die
sich für eine Aussöhnung zwischen Israel
und den Bürgern und Bürgern in Gaza z.B
eingesetzt haben auf feiernde
Jugendliche und deshalb kann es auch
nicht sein dass weiter die große Gefahr
besteht dass mit Raketen auf Israel
geschossen wird und das ist das was das
Selbstverteidigungsrecht ausmacht
gleichzeitig geht es natürlich darum
jede Chance zu nutzen die Zahl der
zivilen Opfer zu reduzieren und das auch
bei allem was man tut jeweils zu
beachten
entsprechend soll auch agiert werden und
für uns ist es deshalb ganz wichtig dass
wir uns einsetzen für das was jetzt
notwendig ist das betrifft humanitäre
Hilfe die nach Gaza gelangen soll wir
haben das sehr früh gemacht wir haben
auch dafür gesorgt dass es tatsächlich
gelingen kann und sind auch unverändert
dabei das zu tun wie Sie wissen ist
Deutschland ein Land das ganz vorne
dabei ist wenn es um solche humanitäre
Hilfe geht nicht nur jetzt sondern auch
vorher schon aber jetzt immer auch denn
die Zivilbevölkerung in ist ja auch
Geisel der Hamas die für ihre eigenen
machtpläne gewissermaßen die Bevölkerung
dort als Schutzschild benutzt wir setzen
uns dafür ein dass kranke Gasa verlassen
können und behandelt werden in
Krankenhäusern der Region aber auch
anderswo und da sind viele auch wir
bereit unseren Beitrag zu leisten dass
medizinische Behandlung möglich wird es
ist so dass wir unbedingt uns dafür
einsetzen dass diejenigen die eine
fremde Nationalität haben Gaza verlassen
können können und wir setzen uns auch
dafür ein dass eine Möglichkeit besteht
dass alles dafür getan wird dass die
Geiseln die die has genommen hat
bedingungslos freigelassen werden
darüber sprechen wir vielen die Einfluss
haben mit der türkischen Regierung
genauso wie mit z.B der Regierung mit
Qatar mit dem ägyptischen Präsidenten
und vielen weil es eine gemeinsame
Einflussnahme geben muss die darauf
hinwirkt dass die Geiseln der Hamas
freigelassen werden und damit das
möglich ist haben wir uns z.B auch im
Europäischen Rat darauf verständigt dass
wir wollen dass es Feuer Pausen gibt
immer mal wieder welche in denen dann
z.B die geiselfreilassung stattfinden
kann in der z.B foreign nationals das
Gaza verlassen können in der humanitäre
Hilfe reingelangen kann aber das ändert
nichts daran dass die Notwendigkeit
existiert die
Selbstverteidigung Israels auch möglich
zu machen und nicht in Frage zu
stellen die nächste Frage glaube ich als
zweites vielen dank Michael Fischer
Deutsche Presseagentur herr Präsident
Erdogan sie haben in den letzten Wochen
nach dem Terrorangriff der herramass auf
Israel mit mehreren Äußerungen für
Irritation gesorgt auch für Empörung
gesorgt nicht nur hier in Deutschland
sondern auch bei einigen anderen ihrer
NATO Bündnispartner ich würde da ger ger
nachfragen wie sie diese Äußerung
gemeint haben zu allererst würde ich
gerne wissen ob sie sich zum
Existenzrecht Israels bekennen das hier
in Deutschland ja zur Staatsraison zählt
ich würde auch gerne wissen was sie
meinen wenn sie Israel Faschismus
vorwerfen und mit welcher Begründung
nennen sie den israelischen
Militäreinsatz gegen die Hamas
Völkermord
und wie begründen sie dass sie die Hamas
eine
Befreiungsorganisation nennen die
hunderte Menschen in Israel ermordet hat
und die von fast allen ihrer natopartner
als Terrororganisation eingestuft wird
und Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben die
Verbalattacken des türkischen
Präsidenten auf Israel schon als absurd
bezeichnet sind sie wirklich nur absurd
aus ihrer Sicht oder gefährden sie auch
die deutscht-türkischen Beziehung und
die Zusammenarbeit mit der Türkei in der
NATO und was bedeutet das konkret z.B
für Rüstungsexporte der türkische
Präsident hat gerade gesagt dass er da
keine Begrenzung erwartet für
Rüstungsexporte die Türkei wünscht sich
40 € Fighter wird Deutschland diesem
Rüstungsexport zustimmen unter diesen
umstellen
zunächst
Länder in NATO unter den ersten Fünf
sind wir als Land als
Türkei und in der NATO ist die Türkei
natürlich nicht nur irgendein Land ist
unter den ersten
Fünf und in der NATO
egal welche Gesinnung welche Einstellung
und so
weiter ganz egal zwischen Russland und
der
Ukraine wer
ist auf der Seite der Ukraine alle und
wir aber sprechen mit der Ukraine
sprechen aber auch mit
Russland und unterscheiden auch nicht
zwischen diesen beiden Ländern in dem
Sinne aber 3 Millionen
Tonn Getreide über ein
getreidekorridor haben wir nach Europa
nach Afrika vermitteln können das war
unser
Land und jetzt sagen sie
hunderte und ich sage oder sie sagen
hunderte ich sage
tausende
Palästinenser werden oder wurden von
Israel getötet nicht WR die
Krankenhäuser wurden vernichtet ich die
Gebetshäuser wurden zerbomt die Kirchen
wurden verbomt ich als
Muslim störe mich
daran sie als Christ stört es Sie nicht
dass die Kirchen zerbomt
werden und warum gibt es keine
Reaktion man müsste doch Reaktion
zeigen für uns gibt es in diesem
Zusammenhang in der Region wenn wir von
Juden von Christen von Muslimen sprechen
keinen Unterschied das darf es auch
nicht geben und ich selbst bin auch
immer gegen sozusagen die Einstellung
wenn man eben gegen Juden wäre also
gegen
Antisemitismus bin ich gewesen der sich
eingesetzt
hat aber sie sprechen z.B von
Deutschland es gibt so viel
Unterstützung von deutscher seit oder
oder Eurofighter ob jetzt wir das von
Deutschland aus bekommen oder nicht es
gibt viele Länder die Kampflugzeuge
herstellen ist ja nicht nur
Deutschland das kann man natürlich auch
von anderen Ländern
besorgen und drohen beispielsweise
undbemannte Hersteller von solchen
drohen ist die Türkei momentan auch ganz
vorne als
pressvertreter sollten Sie uns damit
nicht
drohen fragen Sie oder stellen Sie uns
solche
Fragen die gewissenhaft sind die
menschlich sind und wo wir dann auch
entsprechende Antworten drauf geben
können vielen Dank
zunächst mal möchte ich unterstreichen
dass was ich vorhin auch schon gesagt
habe die Rolle der Türkei bei der
Ermöglichung eines getreideabkommens
zwischen Ukraine und Russland oder einer
Vereinbarung über den Getreideexport aus
der Ukraine und aus Russland war sehr
wichtig der generalvekretär der
Vereinten Nationen und der türkische
Präsident haben sich da sehr hervorgetan
und noch mal das war eine wichtige
Vermittlung die dort geleistet word ist
und noch mal ist es sehr bedauerlich
dass Russland sich aus dieser
Vereinbarung zurückgezogen hat Gott sei
Dank ist es mittlerweile gelungen
getreideexorte aus der Ukraine auch auf
anderem Wege zu organisieren das ändert
aber nichts dass wir unverändert alles
dafür tun müssen dass es wieder zu
miteinander vereinbarten Regelung kommen
wie sie in dieser Black Sea grain
Initiative festgelegt waren ich will
noch mal den Standpunkt den Deutschland
hat unterstreichen der Angriff der Hamas
führt dazu dass Israel sich schützen
muss und sich verteidigen muss können
muss gegen die Angriffe die dort von
dort aus ausgegangen sind es kann nicht
dabei bleiben dass eine
Terrororganisation die diese Region
beherrscht von dort aus mit unglaublich
viel militärischer Gewalt immer wieder
solche Aktivitäten unternimmt das muss
ein Ende finden und das ist etwas was
ein Ziel ist dass man unterstützen muss
wir jedenfalls tun es und deshalb geht
es darum dass man gleichzeitig alles
unternimmt um die Zahl der zivilen Opfer
so gering wie möglich zu halten denn das
stimmt und das ist etwas was für alle
Menschen gelten sollte man kann keinen
Unterschied machen zwischen den zivilen
Toten die entstehen egal woher sie
kommen es muss wichtig sein dass wir
Mitleiden mit denjenigen die sterben
infolge des Krieges zwischen der Hamas
und Israel und das ist eine Position die
für uns wichtig ist deshalb also unsere
humanitäre Hilfe deshalb aber auch
gleichzeitig die klare Position dass die
von der Mass genommenen Geiseln
freigelassen werden müssen ich will das
noch einmal unterstreichen für uns
jedenfalls bleibt es dabei dass es jetzt
notwendig ist auch für eine langfristige
friedvolle Perspektive dass die Hamas
nicht mehr in der Lage sein kann diese
aggressionshandlung vorzunehmen wie wir
sie am 7 Oktober gesehen haben wir sind
wie sie merken in gut Gesprächen
miteinander trotz unterschiedlicher
Meinung und das genau ist auch das was
richtig und wichtig ist in dieser
speziellen Situation denn es bleibt ja
alles dafür zu tun dass es eine gute
Perspektive gibt mit Israel und ein
palästinensischen Staat friedlich
nebeneinander das ist die zwei
staatenlösung die Deutschland die
Europäische Union aber auch viele andere
ja schon lange vertreten und die muss
die Perspektive der Zukunft sein ich
danke Ihnen me D me
her
[Musik]
g so und von Berlin aus kommen wir jetzt
wieder zurück in unser Boner Phönix
Studio soweit die kurze Pressekonferenz
des deutschen Bundeskanzlers und des
türkischen Präsidenten Erdogan bei mir
im Studio ist immer noch Atila asrak
Journalist mit türkischen Wurzeln also
der Bundeskanzler hat noch mal seine
Position zu Israel klar gemacht dann hat
der türkische Präsident ich würde sagen
gefühlt doppelt so lange gesprochen und
natürlich kam auch hier er bleibt bei
seiner Position es geht jetzt darum eine
gemeinsame Linie zu finden eine
gemeinsame Lösung zu finden in diesem
Konflikt das macht vielleicht Hoffnung
aber ansonsten würden Sie sagen würden
sie soweit gehen dass sie sagen der
türkische Präsident hat ja als er
angefangen hat zu sprechen gesagt also
ich will ganz offen sein und er hat ja
alles auf den Tisch gepackt der hat
gesagt wir stehen seit 52 Jahren und
Warten an der Tür der Europäischen Union
und niemand lässt uns rein und er hat
wirklich das alles noch mal ganz
deutlich gemacht klingt das so ein
bisschen wie eine Kampfansage ähm
da also was mir ganz besonders
aufgefallen ist war dass Olaf Scholz äh
sehr zurückhaltend angefangen hat und
zwar er hat mit dem Russland Ukraine
Konflikt angefangen und mit dem
getreidekorridor dann ist er zu NATO
Schweden Aufnahme in die NATO
weitergemacht dann erst ist er zum
Nahostkonflikt gekommen und danach auch
diese ganzen
flüchtlingsabkommens Fragen und äh auch
er hat ja auch Muslime in de Deutschland
genannt und dann die wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit aber das hat er eben er
ist nicht mit der Tür ins Haus
gefallen dann kam Erdogan und er hat wie
sie auch bemerkt haben hat er alles auf
den Tisch gebracht ne gelegt und hat
aber schon in seinen ersten Sätzen
sofort Israel als Lügner bezeichnet er
hat ja auch gesagt Palästina da steht
also da steht im Gen n mehr da ist alles
dem Erdboden gleich gemacht er hat von
den 13000 ermordeten palästinensischen
Kindern gesprochen genau genau und hat
dann auch eben diese
babymörder Beschuldigung noch mal
aufgenommen und das ist ja in der Türke
eutig Position für die Hamas ergriffen
ne die
Frage und dann hat er natürlich auch
über eine humanitäre Waffenruhe prochen
und dass er da bereit ist als Türkei und
als Erdogan eben höchstpönlich
eine Vermittlerrolle zu übernehmen die
Frage ist natürlich wenn er so auf einer
Seite steht kann er dann noch vermitteln
ist er dafür eigentlich der richtige
Mann weil Israel hat natürlich bis jetzt
gesagt also wenn wir hier eine richtige
Feuerpause machen in der Zeit sammelt
sich die chamas wieder mit ihren
Unterstützern und
also dann muss jeder Jude im Prinzip um
sein Leben fürchten es ist ja also es
ist so dass Israel die Türkei auf keinen
Fall als Vermittler
akzeptieren wird
da eben Erdogan mit seinem
mit seinem Afron gegen Israel eben
vieles kaputt gemacht hat
eigentlich die Türkei und Israel hatten
eigentlich kein schlechtes Verhältnis
allerdings ist es jetzt natürlich
wirklich
die Türen sind jetzt verschlossen also
die und die noch mal aufzumachen
in kurzer Zeit in so einer Situation das
wird nicht möglich sein für die Türkei
ist der Zug erstmal abgefahren der
jordanische König wird da wahrscheinlich
eher eine Vermittlerrolle übernehmen
werden und weil da der hat sehr gute
Kontakte sowohl zu den Palästinensern
und auch zu Israel
letztendlich ich in wie weit und da noch
so mitspielen das kann man nicht sagen
meine Frage wäre nur noch ganz kurz weil
unsere Zeit langsam zu Ende geht wie
sieht es denn aus also es sah ja klang
ja zumindestens kompromissbereit die
Wiederbelebung des EU
migrationsabkommens
z.B also das dafür ist Erdogan
eigentlich hier er hat ja auch noch mal
die also die das die visab beefreiung
für türkische Staatsbürgerinnen und
Bürger genannt
oder die visaerleichterung genannt was
wichtig ist dann hat er das
flüchtlingsabkommen genannt und er hat
natürlich auch noch mal gesagt äh mit
der äh Mitgliedschaft bei der EU oder
eben diese privilegierte Partnerschaft
eben
dass da was passieren muss das sehe ich
als Zeichen von das ist das was Sie
gesagt haben er kommt nicht als
bitsteller ne genau genau ja unsere Zeit
ist jetzt leider schon vorüber und wir
machen jetzt weiter ich höre gerade aus
der Regie wir haben ein AK Ellen Beitrag
zur Lage in Israel vorliegen da gab es
heute die Nachrichten ich höre nicht
welchen
Beit ja a gut ich höre gerade ja live
ist live liebe Zuschauer so ist das halt
wir senden jetzt ein phöniix persönlich
mit Alexander
Kehler
[Musik]
Führungskräfte leiden an
Selbstüberschätzung ist das ein
boshaftes Vorurteil oder ist da was dran
unser heutiger Gast hat empirisch also
wissenschaftlich versucht diese Frage zu
beantworten mit Hilfe der
Verhaltensökonomie